- What's up Believe Nation, it's Evan.
My one word is believe and I believe that
you have something special to offer
and I love to see it explode so that
you can help change the planet.
So to help you on your journey today
we're going to talk about seven
ways to deal with failure.
- [Narrator] Nine, eight.
(hip hop music)
As an entrepreneur it's really hard
and you're going to get a
ton of failure along the way.
Not all your ideas are going to work out
you're going to fail and fail and fail.
Eventually getting to your
point of success hopefully.
But dealing with that
failure can be really tough
until today I want to share with you
my seven ways and how
to deal with failure.
(hip hop music)
Way number one is to
change your perspective.
One of the things that I've learned
from watching so many videos
of successful people
across all different fields
from entrepreneurs,
athletes, musicians, actors
everyone, people have had massive success
in multiple fields.
They all talk about
failure as not being final.
Failure is just feedback.
Failure is to be expected.
Failure is part of the process.
- Failure is a stepping stone to success.
- You fail your way to success.
- Failure.
- Failure is
a part of the learning process.
- Success is moving from
one failure to the next.
- To get past your failure you've got to
go through the failure.
- Success is merely the
hangover of failure.
- You should seek failures.
- Learn from those
mistakes and get smarter.
- And I think too many
people fail the first time
they fail once like you try
something that doesn't work
and you feel like I can't do this,
I'm not meant to be an entrepreneur.
I'm not meant to be an actor.
I'm not meant to do that
because the first thing
you did you failed that.
Expect this off you will
fail at the beginning
whatever you touch
is likely not going to
work the first time out.
Mostly because you don't
know what you're doing yet
but you can pick it up
and learn really quickly.
And expect to fail multiple times
where if you find the people
who've had the most success
are usually the people
who failed the most.
If you look at my channel I failed
with tons of series.
I failed with more series
than most people try
than even ever get going with.
And so I learn from those failures
and thankfully not everything failed.
Some of the work then we keep
the winners and keep going.
And keep trying.
And so I think if you were to
watch videos or for me it's the videos
but if you're reading blog so just
surround yourself with
people who have failed a lot
and had success to help
just shift that mindset
that failure is not this one-time thing
and then you suck as a human being.
That you're going to fail
it's okay, it's normal.
It's part of the process.
And the more you fail the
more you're going to win.
If you are surrounded
by that and you start to
believe that, you change your perspective,
then you won't take it as personally
and you'll see it as a win to help you get
closer to where you want to go.
(hip hop music)
Way number two is to fail more.
The more you try anything
the better you get at it
right, so the more you fail
you're building the muscle.
The more you fail the more
comfortable you get with it.
And it's not that you always want to fail
you just want to be a constant
failure your entire life.
Right, there will be
successes along the way.
But if you fail and it doesn't
go well and then refuse
to even try anything in the future
that's the ultimate failure.
Right and so getting
comfortable with failure
and not being defined by failure,
and not taking failure so personally,
not taking failure as because
this idea you have didn't work
that means that you suck as a human being.
Right, to be able to detach those two
the more you fail, the more you try,
the more you get used to it,
the less important the
failure itself becomes
and more important achieving
whatever the goal is becomes.
And so just fail more
try more things, fail again, fail again,
fail again and what you
find is every time you
feel a little bit smarter,
a little bit bette.
It's not doing the same thing the same way
every single time
but you get a little bit
better and you start to see
that the failure wasn't as big
and you see more results,
more results, more results.
And you just practicing in
failing and feeling better
consistently you'll build that muscle
and then it won't be as scary.
(hip hop music)
Way number three is to
practice being uncomfortable.
A lot of times it's not the failure itself
that we're afraid of,
it's the failure in front of other people
that we're afraid of.
We're afraid of how our
friends are going to judge us,
our parents are going to judge us.
Or how people on social
media are going to judge us.
We're afraid of not the failure
but failing in front of other people.
And so the more you can lose that the more
you can practice being uncomfortable
and caring less what other people think
of your successes or your failures
or of you in general, then the less likely
you're going to carry that failure around
and just feel like a terrible human being
and feel worthless, you will release it.
And so I try to build a muscle of
whenever I feel uncomfortable in something
I'll step into the discomfort.
Filming here at the start
right, so there's people walking by
there's people looking in the glass.
There's people wondering what's going on.
It was nerve-racking at the start
but because I felt uncomfortable with it,
I had to do it, I had to release it.
And now I could walk in
and it doesn't matter,
I'm used to it, right.
The first time I filmed
in public same thing,
I have to go out and do it.
You know I got a got to
release that uncomfortableness.
And the first time I did it
I was walking down the street
and then somebody came close so
I kind of was quiet and then they left.
And then I could continue
to film and slowly, slowly,
slowly I got used to it where
if somebody's watching it doesn't matter
I'm okay with it, I don't
care about their judgment .
So again, the more you
step into uncomfortableness
as a general rule if you
ever feel yourself playing
small because of
somebody else's potential opinion,
potential opinion, you don't
know what their opinion is.
Just their potential opinion of you,
whenever you can catch
that a lot of times it's so
subconscious that you don't catch it.
Whenever you can catch it I
encourage you to step into it.
One last example I've
told a couple times was
when I was walking in the
street and listening to
music and I'm dancing and doing you know
big movements and then I get to the corner
of a busy intersection and I start
I start dancing small then I stop
because there's people around me.
And I was worried about their judgment
and so I didn't do anything.
And when I caught it I realized
I will not play small because of their
potential judgment of me.
I'm not doing anything that is going to be
harmful to them right.
Like I'm not going up in their face
and causing a scene.
I'm just having fun on my own.
And so then I just started
dancing even bigger
on the street corner because I needed to
release that fear.
And so getting used to being uncomfortable
when you feel the fear of discomfort,
learn to jump into it,
build the muscle and you'll
feel failure a lot less.
(hip hop music)
- Tip number four is
to believe in yourself.
Failure is inevitable, it's part of life.
It's going to happen.
I have had many failures in my life.
Anywhere from accidentally wearing a
transparent dress to work
to failing at a decade-long career.
And that was a big deal for me.
I remember walking away from a career
that seemed so lucrative and so promising
because I lost passion for it.
And people around me started
to question my sanity.
They started questioning
my decision-making.
And they even turned their backs on me.
And a lot of those people
I called my friends
at that time.
And I remember sitting at the edge of my
bed thinking to myself this,
wow,
this is what life has become.
I felt the lowest of lows
because at that time I
measured my success based on
my finances and my social status.
And I had neither.
All I saw was darkness around me.
But I had this tiny glimpse of hope
and this tiny glimpse of life.
And I believed in myself, I believed that
I was going to pull through.
And I did.
I invested all my time
into growing myself,
to developing resilience
and I grew a thicker skin.
And just a few years later I was given an
opportunity to start a business with Evan.
And that would have never happened
unless I did walk away from that career
all those years ago.
And that's the thing,
if you are experiencing failure right now
I know how it feels.
There's darkness all around you.
But remember, there's something beautiful
and amazing on the other
side of your failure.
And always, always believe in yourself.
(hip hop music)
- Way number five is focus
on the lesson learned.
If you can find the positive in everything
that you're doing it makes it a lot easier
to do it again.
If you fail and it didn't work out
it's easy to stay in
that negative down zone
of, I suck and this idea
is never going to work
and I'll never be an entrepreneur.
And you know you just keep wallowing
and into this downward spikel, spikel.
Cycle spiral, spiral and cycle spikel,
we created new words her.
And you keep spiraling
downwards where if you can find
something positive from i.
Okay well that didn't work,
but I found this.
I learned this about myself right.
The famous Edison you
know, who failed with the
light bulb, I didn't fail 999 times
I found 990 ways 900 anyways not how not
to do it right, like that famous quote.
If you can learn a lesson from it
if you can understand
that I learned something
from here then it's not a failure
because you learned, because you grew.
There was a benefit.
So trying to find some kind
of benefit from that failure
can bring the optimism back up
and get you back on the horse and go try
and do something else.
(hip hop music)
Way number six is have
honest conversations.
This is particularly for the people
who are afraid of failing
in front of other people,
or afraid of failing and being judged.
Whether that's your friends, the family,
the people around you.
Having an honest conversation you know
if you are afraid to start your business
because of what your mom might think,
or what your best friend might think
if it doesn't work out,
then I would sit down
and try to have an honest conversation.
Say, listen, I really
want to do this thing.
I'm really scared I don't know
if it's going to work out.
It may not work out.
It's the scariest thing
I've ever done in my life.
And the thing is
preventing me from doing it
is because I don't want
to fail in front of you.
I'm worried about your judgment
and how you may see me as a son,
as a friend, as a brother, as a
whatever the relationship is.
I just wanted to let you
know that this is the thing
that's holding me back.
Now most people will hopefully say,
well that's crazy like
if you want to do it
you should do it.
I'm cheering you on,
I'm going to support you
and I'd love to see you have the success.
Some people won't you know
some people will say, this
is the stupidest idea ever.
What are you talking about?
Like don't go and be an entrepreneur,
you're going to fail for sure.
Yeah so you may not
get the result you want
but at least for me at least
try, at least it there's
if there's a 40% chance of it working out,
at least being able to
release that demon and get
their support and have them kind of
cheering you on and then when you do
fail because you will at some point,
they have your back and
their understanding.
Just in general for relationships
any kind of relationship
communication is important.
Instead of just playing
a surface level game
to really be vulnerable and
share the things that are
on our minds is super important.
So it may not work out but I definitely
recommend having the conversation
to at least try to get that win.
(hip hop music)
And way number seven is just to decide to
live your life.
Like at some point you have to decide
this is my life, if I fail it's okay.
I cannot continue to live my parents life,
my friends life, my cultures life
because of what people
are telling me to do.
When you were growing up, sure.
When you're three years
old you know you're
you're following your parents around you
you rely on them for food and to survive.
But when you're, pick an age.
16, 18,
25, 30
like at some point you have to say,
this is my life I'm going
to do what I want to do.
And if it doesn't work out that's okay.
But I'm not just going to live my life
according to your expectations.
You know like if you're
worried about your mom's
opinion and you're 40-years-old,
are you still going to
live your life by her
at 50-years-old?
Like how much of your life
are you going to waste
living to other people's
expectations instead of
living your own life.
And it just comes from deciding like
I am deciding that I am going to do this.
It may work, it may not work.
I'm doing it for me
I don't care about the opinions
of the people around me.
If you can't support me in me doing
the thing that I want to do
then that's a problem right.
Then maybe you limit your access to them
or at least you don't talk
about those things with them.
But it doesn't prevent
you from moving forward.
Other people's expectations
of you should not
prevent you from playing
the game you want to play.
Because if you're just
playing up to other people's
expectations you're going to be playing
small your entire life.
So it's just deciding to live your life.
So those are my tips on the seven ways
to deal with failure.
I made this video because
anikyt asked me to.
If there's a topic you'd
like me to cover in a future
several ways video check out
the link in the description.
Go there cast your vote, have your say
and I just might do it.
I'd love to know what did
you think of the seven tips,
which one resonated with you the most,
you're going to try and
apply it in your life
or in your business somehow.
Leave it down in the comments below.
Did I miss an eight, nine, ten
that you want to add
that you want to share with Believe Nation
add some value, add some
love leave it down there
in the comment section below, as well.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to M.D. McGill
AKA TridentLion.
Thank you so much for
your support of my book
Your One Word, picking up a copy,
doing a review posting to Twitter.
I really really really appreciate it
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed the book.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you hope, I you continue to
believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.